So we know we can identify a ratio
by seeing if it's comparing
two quantities that have the same units,
comparing dentist to dentists or
graduates to graduates, but
which quantity comes first?
To answer this question,
I like to think to myself,
how could I phrase this
as a out of b something.
And let me explain what I mean,
when we had the statement, three out
of five dentists recommend Toothtaste,
the tasty toothpaste, our ratio was
three out of five, three over five.
In this case three dentist was my a and
five dentists was my b.
Or we could think it as three
was my a and five was my b, but
when we had the statement out of 500
grads, 200 got jobs in business.
Well, I could not say 500 out of
200 grads got jobs in business,
that's wrong.
So I could not write 500 out of 200 or
5 out of 2.
However, I could have rephrased this as,
200 out of 500 grads
got jobs in business.
And now 200 is my a, 500 is my b and
my ratio is 200 out of 500 or
2 out of 5.
So it looks like once I can
phrase something as a out of b,
then I can say that
the ratio is a over b.
Let's do a little bit of practice.
So for the following ratios, select
which quantity goes in the numerator.
Three out of four students are girls.
For every 17 cars on the road,
2 are unregistered.
And for every 90 babies,
32 will live to be 100.
For each of these three statements,
select the appropriate button for
the quantity that belongs
in the numerator.